hier encore on aurait parlé de science
fiction aujourd'hui c'est la réalité on
a réussi à greffer vendredi dernier ce
coeur de pas un être humain et cinq
jours plus tard le patient est toujours
en vie
57 ans avait épuisé toutes les autres
possibilités médicale un dernier recours
il a accepté d'être le cobaye de cette
première mondiale
mais
l'équipe de chirurgie de l'université du
maryland à pratiquer ce qu'on appelle
une dizaine au greffe la transplantation
d'un organe animal un humain
le coeur du port qui n'avaient pas
atteint sa maturité a été modifié
génétiquement pour que l'organe cesse de
se développer mais aussi pour diminuer
le risque de rejet par le patient
c'est un véritable tour de force sur le
plan scientifique
c'est une grande perte dans ce
feuilleton peut pas se cacher mais
capable de modifier donc génétiquement
pour rendre les tissus comme invisible
au système immunitaire des humains c'est
une première
recherche une première scientifique
l'intervention s'est déroulée sans
complications majeures et dès que la
greffe a été complété du nouveau au
coeur du patient ainsi mis à battre
normalement dans sa poitrine c'est sur
le patient doit recevoir des médicaments
biologiques à l'occasion
mais écoutez c'est une première et puis
l'objectif de l'équipe dumoulin et bien
sûr de pallier au manque criant
d'organes disponibles pour les très
nombreuses demandes de transplantation
partout dans le monde s'ils ont réussi à
transplanter un coeur de port avec
succès tous les espoirs pourrait être
permis
elle est la toute première xénogreffes
de cas a eu lieu au début des années 80
sur un très jeune enfant baby fait qui a
reçu l'organe d'un primate avant de le
rejeter 21 jours plus tard les normands
grondin radio canada montréal